[Music]
well the music means it's time for the
press preview our first look at what's
on the front pages as they arrive uh
time to see what's making the headlines
with the observers chief leader writer
sonia soda and the chief executive of
conservative home mark wallace they will
be with us from now until just before
midnight but before we turn to them
let's take a quick look through the
front pages that we have and we start
with the telegraph it leads with rishi
sunak being accused of a screeching
u-turn on tax cuts as he pledged to
scrap vat on energy bills for a year if
he becomes prime minister
they express praises liz truss for
promising to cut serious crime by 20 if
she gets the top job
the sun splashes on england's win at the
euros setting the stage for a final
showdown with germany or france on
sunday
the metro has word of a fresh set of
train and tube strikes which were
announced today
meanwhile the ft reports a number of
consumer product companies such as
mcdonald's coca-cola and unilever are
putting up their prices because of the
increase in costs they're facing
a report by the uk spending watchdog
says that ministers and government
officials did little to deal with
potential conflicts of interest when
awarding covert contracts to a
healthcare firm according to the
guardian
and here is the star which quotes
heathrow airport's boss who says that
people are clogging up airports by
faking injuries so they can get a
wheelchair and jump the cues a picture
from little britain i think there
just a reminder by scanning the qr code
that you will see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of the papers posture watching us
uh we are joined tonight as mentioned by
sonia soda and mark wallace lovely to
see both of you do hope you're well um
mark we'll start with you first uh this
sir take us to the front of the
telegraph i mean the the we we
understand their favorite candidate
perhaps in in this context but someone
has described what uh rishi surak is
planning as a screeching u-turn explain
story
so this has been rumored for the last
couple of days richie sunak started his
campaign um trying to distinguish
himself from some of his rivals who were
promising tax cuts here and tax cuts
there as a fiscal red meat to the tory
membership he started his campaign by
deliberately casting himself the only
way he really could which is say
actually i think they'll be
irresponsible i'm not going to be hasty
uh reading between the lines i used to
be chancellor only a few weeks ago and
i'm not going to criticize the tax
policy that i was in charge of um the
fact that he's now seeming to change
tack points to a number of things
firstly it's the fact that
his campaign is evidently feeling some
heat from liz truss who is making a
strong argument that we should cut taxes
now is an important conservative measure
to help with the cost of living and and
to spark better economic growth but also
points the fact that frankly in the
polls so far he's behind and so if one
strategy isn't working then you know you
might as well roll the dice and try
another sonia i mean do you think the
strategy is likely to work i mean the
telegraph says this move will cost us
what 4.3
billion pounds i mean isn't it rishi
sunak's mantra that the unfunded tax
cuts proposed by liz liz trust herself
but it's going to be our children that
are going to have to pay for them it's
going to have to be our children's
children doesn't the same argument apply
to his tax cut
i mean i think there's an argument that
it absolutely does i guess what he's
banking on is that liz trust is
promising more tax cuts so if somebody's
really concerned about sort of fiscal
rectitude um and is casting a vote in
this contest they may still go for rishi
sunak i think that's what he's
banking on but i think just to sort of
take a step back from this um i think
lots of members of the public will be
watching this feeling quite frustrated
actually that they don't get a say
between these two candidates it's
obviously quite a small pool of people
who get to vote 160 000 or so
conservative party members and i think
that's what we're seeing in this contest
we're seeing two politicians pitching
themselves to conservative members who
sit to the right of the average voters
the average voter um and so it feels
like quite an insular conversation that
has so far focused on tax cuts we saw
you know really awful headlines i think
over the weekend where they were trying
to out-compete each other on essentially
being quite cruel to refugees um and so
i i i do think this contest just has a
very strange feel about it because
at the end of the day the next prime
minister is being selected and it is a
very very very small unrepresented
sliver of the electorate who gets a say
and i think that's what we're seeing
play out
um ah fun just to write on cue i'm
getting handy it's a couple of papers uh
by our floor floor manager here um
let's have a quick look then at the
front of the uh at the front of the
times um uh
rishi sunak ditching v80 on energize
again
we get this idea but
what just pick up on that point from
sonja it's on you if you can mark i mean
with this very very small very very
select group of individuals i mean you
know the red meat that's being chucked
out elsewhere i see you're curbing
militant unions again a topic that will
that would certainly please a a large
number of the of the conservative
membership at some point they do have to
deliver on these promises don't they
of course they do i would say just
rewinding a minute um a tax cut doesn't
cost us 4.3 billion pounds it means
leaving 4.3 billion pounds in british
people's pockets which they which they
really need at the time when uh
when when the cost of living is rising
so fast when the tax takes already so
high there is an important issue as
sonia says it is important to remember
that this is about choosing a prime
minister there are a number of stages
this of course the conservative party
has the right to choose its own leader
and of course the leader of the new uh
government in this conservative majority
parliament has to command the uh faith
and confidence of a majority of mps
and under those you know that big
conservative majority need to be able to
get on with things so i think you know
you would expect me to say of course
it's right that the conservative party's
members get to vote on who their leader
is but it's still important um you know
to speak to what sonia was saying that
this debate has got to reach out to the
wider country this is also a time fine
to win the confidence of conservative
party members but the next prime
minister whoever wins this race they
should be using this moment to set out
their stall to the whole country and i i
definitely think they've been moments in
this uh race already in which i think
we've seen a bit too much uh negativity
um interestingly i think in tonight's
debate there was some suggestion that
rishi sunak's um kind of approach to
engaging in debate was um some somewhat
more um kind of modifying than it was a
couple of days ago which which is
reported to have gone down pretty badly
with people um previously um but it's
really important that everyone gets on
the front foot one thing i'd like to
stop hearing for example is supporters
of one candidate or another saying only
my candidate can win the election can
govern well or it can compete labor i
just don't think that's the case and
it's also not something that colleagues
should say about each other yeah well
good luck with that we'll see if
anyone's going to listen to you i'm
sonia the front of the daily express
again a kind of a a liz trust uh your
policy proposal laying down the law
demanding police cut crime by 20 the
headline no ifs or buts police must
solve more crimes
isn't the problem with kind of policy
announcements like this you know the
fact that the conservatives have been in
government since 2010.
yes absolutely and liz trust has been
part of a government that hasn't
delivered on the police solving more
crimes i think that's absolutely one
issue the second issue is is there not
very much information in this story
about how it's going to be achieved
there's no acknowledgement actually
about the numbers of police cuts the
fact that there are fewer police
officers on the streets now than there
have been you know times in the recent
past as a result of cuts the police
force so no one's saying that the police
is perfect i mean obviously if you look
at issues like a force like the met has
had with institutional corruption and
institutional racism and misogyny and
homophobia um you know there are clear
issues with the police and the police
need to reform but just sort of you know
giving a few newspaper front pages where
you say they have to do better in terms
of solving crime when when the number of
bubbies on the beat has been cut cut um
it just doesn't cut it and i think again
this speaks to a broader issue in this
contest and yes boris johnson may have
stepped down as prime minister but there
was something about that style of
johnson politics where johnson just kind
of blathered and you know actually quite
frankly completely misled the public for
example when he said the northern
ireland protocol that he'd signed did
not involve a border down the rcc and he
just basically lied to the public about
that and we've lost something in our
politics as a result of that and we now
see
you know there is still this this style
in politics johnson may have gotten but
i think soon af and trust are very much
heirs to it you've got trust just sort
of saying well the police must do better
without setting out a plan for it
without any acknowledgement that that
she's been part of a government in
recent years that has failed to do good
do well enough on crime so i i
personally think the public will will
see past this um there's no plan and
you're not taking responsibility for the
government that you what the government
that you you've been part of um has
failed to achieve and i think just
saying to people this will happen and
i'll make sure it happens i think trust
in politicians is low at the moment and
i don't think it washes
and mark as we look at page four of the
metro let's let's reflect briefly shall
we on poor kate mccann i'm someone i'm
sure both of you know x of this parish
was a political correspondent here now
talk tv's a political editor who was
hosting the debate poor cates frankly
she is all right but but barack they
brought the debate to a bit of an abrupt
conclusion
yes and i i think the first thing to
focus on is obviously as you say that we
hear that she's okay which is a great
relief i'm sure to uh not not just uh
the three of us here who
know her personally but to an awful lot
of people who will be acquainted with
her excellent work and i think frankly
she was doing a fantastic job in the in
the debate this evening her co-host had
already had to pull out beforehand
having tested positive for kovitz
you know a great relief that she's okay
and you know very much a shocking moment
obviously people at home uh me included
didn't didn't know what was happening
but you could you could see written on
liz truster's face as seen in several of
the newspapers that it was a shocking
and and worrying moment
uh yeah but i said thankfully everything
grand um sonia mark we will pause there
for just a second stay right where you
are uh but coming up after the break
guess what we'll be talking about this
story the lionesses they're on their way
to wembley we will be reflecting on a
remarkable euros semi-final victory
after this
[Music]
welcome back mark and sonia still taking
us through this election from the papers
and um sonia let's come to you and we
will both of you we will be talking
about the lionesses in a minute but
you're not having a scotsman celebrating
england for the remaining 10 minutes of
the program let's instead go to the ft
and talk about why european i know i
know we'll get there in a minute let's
go to the front of the ft sonia m
european gas prices have jumped 20
in two days frankly a sign of what might
be coming down the pipeline a little bit
later on this year as well
absolutely so this is as a result of
russia restricting supply of gas the eu
through the nordstrom pipeline
it's something that eu countries have
been worrying about for a very long time
the benefit of hindsight is a fine thing
and i think looking back there were lots
of experts warning that um that
certainly eu countries particularly
germany were too reliant on on russian
gas for it for their own security and
it's now looking um like a real neglect
actually of energy security policy uh
for the continent uh that that sort of
reliance on the russian gas supply was
was allowed to persist for so long but
we are where we are and
this is why prices have spiked so much
because um russia is predictably using
the supply of gas as another sort of
weapon in in the in this obviously you
know it's you know very different to the
the war that it's waging in ukraine but
it is using it as a tool
of its disposable to try and put
pressure on europe and so you've got
people incredibly concerned about what
this means um it for the continent um
there's some thinking that perhaps if
things get really bad um gas could even
be rationed um so it is a very troubling
situation it puts a lot of pressure on
the eu and on the continent
to move very very fast in thinking about
alternative gas supplies and i think
it's a real kind of warning shot that
actually in the medium term
given the status sort of international
affairs and what's going on
um you know tensions with russia and
also china um you know
the continent needs to be much better at
kind of more self-sufficient
let's talk football then shall we mark a
fantastic result by the lionesses four
nil and the cheekiest back heel i think
i've seen in a couple of decades
fantastic result
um
joyful meets for elrika johnson
meatballs anything else you can just
think of um and and fantastic to see but
also as a lot of people have noticed you
know yet another triumph um already for
the lionesses and yet another signal of
how much um
actually for how long we've failed to
pay the proper attention due to the to
the women's game it's amazing to see
it's been brilliant to see the nations
recognize actually some newspapers
front page space tonight for the line
this is a success but you know i also
think about the athletic grassroots
football you know my son
goes to football training every saturday
morning with uh heather a fantastic
female football coach this is the future
of our football and it's it it's
brilliant to see
sonya your thoughts yeah you got a big
smile yeah
i completely agree um my little niece
she plays football she goes to football
every saturday morning um one of my
really good friends daughters she's a
budding player and is a member of a
local league i'm actually going to see
my first ever football match in a
stadium which is the final on sunday
which i'm incredibly excited about
in the works for a long time long before
i knew or thought that england was going
to be playing in the final but i'm very
excited about it but no it's just been
thrilling to follow this tournament and
it really does feel like this is a first
tournament where um women's football you
know is is starting to be on a more even
keel and a more even um footing with
men's football and is getting the credit
that it deserves so um it's an absolute
delight and i thought it was such an
exciting match this evening as well yeah
i mean it's quite something to think of
when i was growing up girls at my school
were not playing football so at the risk
of jinxing it and i want a one word
answer for both of you because we are
about to run out of time
mark sonia is it coming home
yes yes perfect job done